i expect the libs to try to destroy the
soul of our nation frankly i sometimes
think it's funny when they try to do it
they're so hilarious those libs i get
less delight
out of the
wolves in sheep's clothing who attempt
to infiltrate above all our churches
to try to destroy not just the soul of
our nation but our individual souls as
well those people get me a little little
bit angrier and they take to the
preferred medium of these demons a
tick-tock to spread their anti-gospel so
our producers have found all the dumbest
woke religious arguments you've ever
seen this is brought to you by ring more
from ring in a little bit first though
let's get to the tick tocks jesus
had a same gender lover and i'm about to
show you where gospel of john chapter 13
verse 23. this is hanging with his best
bros the disciples at dinner one day
when he tells them that one of them is
going to betray him soon reclining on
jesus's bosom was one of his disciples
the man jesus loved two important
concepts
reclining
and bosom
reclining meant laying on one side
propped up on some pillows or an elbow
in other translations it's better used
as chest or lap jesus's lover had his
head in jesus's lap
[Music]
make that what you will
the point of all of this queer and trans
people exist we're here
we've always been here we're in the
sacred scriptures perhaps our god is
queer and trans too they can't erase us
even from the text they use against us i
didn't realize how blasphemous this was
going to be worse for me
this is
you know a lot of these i just kind of
get a kick out of their arguments this
actually makes me very very angry
because they are blaspheming our lord
and our god obviously i don't think that
textual evidence that this priestess or
this lady is present or i think a lady i
don't know is presenting is persuasive
that
while jesus is dining with his friends
and disciples
they are reclining while they eat this
is very silly i thought that that she
was going to point to
uh the kiss the the kiss of betrayal
from judas two men kissed this is
evidence of homosexuality or whatever
it's very sad i'm going to try to be i'm
going to try to have a
christian charity and grace here it's
very sad that this sexually confused
woman feels a natural kind of shame and
confusion
in her
ideology
and so she is desperate for the
affirmation
of traditional and good institutions and
ultimately the holy institution the
church and so what does she do for that
does she amend her bizarre fantastical
ideology no she just slaps on a
collar and pretends to be to be a priest
and then
reads the gospel and then ignores the
gospel and tries to shoehorn in her own
sexual fantasies that is very sad she
does deserve our pity god is non-binary
god is queer god is autistic let me
unpack that for you god is non-binary
because god is the author of gender god
is gender-less and genderful they are
neither male nor female and they are
both they refer to themselves both as
male and female throughout the text and
yet theology would tell us that god does
not have gender so by definition god is
non-binary for people who demand that we
all use preferred pronouns it is pretty
rich that they won't use god's preferred
pronoun
god is he
presents himself as he the second person
of the holy trinity is incarnate as a
man with a man's name and a man's body
and a man's pronouns and just as a man
so you have god the father and god the
son and the holy spirit who is the bond
of love between the father and the son
who also uses male pronouns all
sexualities exist in god and yet god is
not explicitly sexual and since
asexuality is part of the lgbtq spectrum
we can say god is queer
and finally god is autistic because
autism is a divergence from typical
neurology and since no being in
existence has a mind like the mind of
god god is by definition neurodivergent
he's making a point that god is
is so different than we are that
therefore he's autistic because autistic
people are
different than
we are i guess is the point he's trying
to make ironically it would really be
the opposite point because man is made
in the image and likeness of god yes
obviously god is perfect god is
omnipotent god is omniscient
god is omni-benevolent those are things
that don't describe me or you or any any
of the rest of us here on earth
and yet
the similarities that we have with god
are far greater
than the differences because we are made
in the imago dei in the image and
likeness of god and we are truly
brothers of christ
the son of god god himself the divine
logic of the universe because we share a
common ancestor in adam and eve for
christians it is we hope no longer i who
lives but but christ who lives in me the
point he's making about the greatness of
god is well taken he's kind of missing
the rest of the story keep going i like
to say god is autistic
god always identifies with and as the
most marginalized people in society god
identifies as a king would you call a
king the most marginalized person in
society in a way the king is unique you
wouldn't say that the king is
a deviant god is not a deviant okay god
is
the
source and summit of goodness and truth
and perfection and beauty we have access
to god
we actually have access to god we also
have the freedom to turn away from god
and to pursue our own perverse desires
and that's our choice but that's a bad
choice
and we shouldn't and that's those sort
of choices should not be celebrated you
know summer's always busy so people are
away from home they're away from home on
vacations i was away from home because i
was in the hospital with my wife while
she was giving birth
and when you're away from home you want
to make sure that your home is protected
that's why you need a ring
now you might be thinking ring you talk
about the video doorbell yeah yeah they
have a great video doorbell you can see
and speak to whoever is at your door no
matter where you are in the world
whether you're in the home you're at the
hospital you're on a vacation you're at
the office wherever did you know that
ring has an award-winning home security
system did you know it has available
professional monitoring when you
subscribe did you know it's super easy
to install did you know even beyond the
award-winning ring alarm that they've
got ring alarm pro
that's right you can be like me you can
become a pro go pro and protect not just
your physical home but your digital home
as well think about how much of your
life you live online
protect those data protect your windows
and your doors from the freeze and the
flood and bad guys and all that protect
your data to
go pro cnet calls ring alarm pro a giant
lead for home security
this busy summer season to protect your
home you've got to check out ring alarm
pro to learn more go to ring.com
michael ring.com
michael next tick tock are all the
transphobic christians gone okay
jesus was trans
look like this to be born male you have
to have an x and a y chromosome these
other presenting combinations other than
x y but we're just doing x y right now
okay y chromosomes can only come from a
male sperm mary didn't have sex with a
male which leaves us with mary only
being able to pass on xxx chromosomes
therefore jesus was born female
but goes around the entire bible and
everyone calls him him and a male
so he's trans the more you know shooting
star
so this guy just i guess missed out on
the nicene creed
and the story of the annunciation jesus
is not a clone of mary jesus is is not
conceived strictly by mary jesus is
conceived by the holy spirit
and incarnate of the virgin mary
and he becomes man and this is the
central part of the of the creed which
we
pray in mass every sunday and actually
this is so solemn one gets down on one's
knees and one says at incarnatus est de
spiritu sancto ex maria virginae et omo
factus est and he is incarnate
of the holy spirit
out of the virgin mary
and he becomes man because it's uh
not just a kind of cloning situation
here the chromosomal thing doesn't work
out also it's obviously miraculous
you've got the divine logic of the
universe the only begotten son of god
becomes man obviously this is miraculous
even at the level of this kind of
pseudo-scientific explanation that woke
tick-tock does not hold up extra deal
i'm a christian and abortions aren't
right
because god is pro-life well actually
numbers chapter 5 verses 13 through 29
god commands abortion if a man even
thinks his wife might have cheated on
him and you got to be taking that out of
context
that don't sound right but but he's
definitely not in the late term
abortions like the democrats
[Music]
actually god would let you abort your
kids
even after they were alive if they were
disobedient deuteronomy 18 verse
21 well well that's all in the old
testament
and we don't care about that but at
least the supreme court got it right
when they put prayer back in school
have you ever read this book
okay jesus actually commanded his
disciples not to pray in public but in
their private life
closets
matthew six verses five and six well i
like it so damn it jesus is talking
about he's not a real christian anyway i
heard him
all right this is
this is like
the all the hits of the really shallow
lib usually atheist retorts to
christianity at numbers chapter five the
question is raised as to whether or not
a man suspects that his wife has
committed adultery and it is said that
she should be brought to the temple and
that the priest of the temple will mix
dirt from the ground with some water and
she'll drink it and if her thigh withers
then she's committed adultery and if not
then she has not committed adultery the
libs have misinterpreted this or i think
probably intentionally twisted this
phrase to mean that the woman is taking
an abortion drug
from the dust of the temple and that god
is commanding an abortion that obviously
is not taking place
and really what's happening in the
social and historical context here is
that it's a protection for women who in
a sort of natural pagan societies i have
very few rights because they're the
weaker sex and if a man suspects a woman
of anything they can just go out and
treat the women however however they
like and this is giving a kind of
protection
for women obviously
the the phrase thigh withering is i
don't really know how one can go from
that to uh you know chopping up babies
in the womb or anything i i think that's
that's very silly the next point that he
makes is that uh
we shouldn't have prayer in schools
because jesus says to pray privately
it's true
jesus does say you shouldn't be a
hypocrite and just pray for the purpose
of getting adulation from everyone in
public so you can go into your innermost
closet but jesus also prays publicly and
prays frequently with his apostles he
teaches the apostles how to pray and he
actually gives them the lord's prayer
our father who art in heaven hallowed be
thy name
christ says do not
have vain repetitious prayers sometimes
this is misinterpreted to suggest that
we shouldn't pray in a formal way or
even in any sort of repetitive way but
we should also point out christ prays in
a repetitive way you just don't want it
to be a vain in a repetitive way he
cites deuteronomy and he says that
god sometimes orders you to kill your
kid even after he's born even after he's
alive as this guy puts it all of which
is to say this actually brings up an
important point the bible does not in
any way embrace abortion in fact you see
repeatedly throughout the bible the
notion that god knows us from before we
were conceived he knows us well we are
in the womb he knows all of the hairs on
our head you see this especially in the
visitation when mary pregnant with the
baby jesus goes and visits elizabeth who
is pregnant with john the baptist little
fetal john the baptist leaps in the womb
because he recognizes the presence of
his lord jesus there both fetuses both
obviously alive and little baby in the
womb john the baptist actually leaping
actually performing an act so
that is always very silly our life is
god's to do with as he pleases no one is
going to live forever ever at least on
this earth we can have eternal life
through jesus but we're all going to die
at some point and and life is the lord's
to take away and but by the way our
relationship to life yours and mine is
very different than god's relationship
to life because god is the author of all
life and our lives ultimately are
dependent at every single moment on god
that we can
disrespect that gift of life and we can
turn away from god the author of our
lives or we can embrace him and live
forever in heaven i hope that clears it
up please send more woke crazy religious
tic-tacs over
over this way and we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]